mich hat heute bewegt Friedrich Merz
oder besser gesagt Friedrich III mein
Kollege Ralf Schuler der auch heute
Abend in der Sendung ist hat nämlich
herausgefunden Friedrich Merz möchte es
noch einmal versuchen spielt noch einmal
Friedrich sozusagen er möchte noch
einmal versuchen CDU-Vorsitzender zu
werden aber unter einer Bedingung dass
diesmal nicht die sogenannten Eliten
abstimmen dürfen nicht die Delegierten
nicht die dir Auskühlen vorher wie
können wir friedlich März verhindern
sondern die Basis der Partei das ist
deine Bedingung wie wir aus seinem aller
engsten Umfeld hören wenn die Basis der
Partei abstimmen darf dann wird er sich
ein drittes Mal zur Wahl stellen ein
drittes Mal versuchen dass er die ersten
zwei Male nicht geschafft hat nämlich
Vorsitzender der Partei zu werden warum
finde ich das gut weil es genau der
Denkzettel ist den es jetzt gerade
braucht die Wahl die ist für die CDU so
verheerend schief gegangen weil man zu
viele Entscheidungen in zu kleinen
Gremien getroffen hat die mit der
Realität im Land rein nichts rein gar
nichts mehr zu tun haben mein liebstes
Beispiel am Ende haben Volker bouf und
Wolfgang Schäuble unter sich ausgemacht
dass Armin Laschet für die CDU in den
Bundestagswahlkampf zieht zwei hoch
verdiente Politiker mit großer
Lebenserfahrung aber auch zwei Männer
die zusammen 150 Jahre alt sind und über
die Zukunft der CDU entscheiden sollten
dass das schief gehen musste war klar
und deswegen von Friedrich Merz aus
meiner Sicht das richtige Zeichen lasst
die Basis darüber entscheiden sie
versteht manches besser als die Eliten
und die Gremien
nun kann man ja über Friedrich Merz
denken was man will alle reden über
Erneuerung aber keiner fängt an
Friedrich Merz hat immerhin eine Debatte
darüber angestoßen wie man künftig den
Spitzenkandidaten auswürfeln sollte und
da ist in Deutschland doch in ganze
Menge Staub auf den Prozess drauf wenn
man sich anguckt wie in Amerika die
vorwahlkämpfe geführt werden wie sich
Leute aus gleichen Parteien gegenseitig
behaken im Dienste der Sache damit am
Ende wirklich der beste der eloquenteste
der Tasse durchkommt Peter Gauweiler hat
seit Jahren korkus ist für Deutschland
gefordert will natürlich keiner weil die
deutsche Politik sich lieber im bequemen
einrichtet das ist eine wichtige Debatte
und Friedrich Merz könnte der Anlass
dafür sein zu sagen okay nicht unbedingt
Mitgliederbefragung allein sondern auch
Auftritte in der Öffentlichkeit sich
durchbeißen müssen das finde ich eine
gute Idee ja und vor allem wäre es eine
gute Absicherung gegen das debake was
die CDU jetzt gerade erlebt aber erster
Teil das Debakels also er ist zweimal
angetreten als CDU-Vorsitzender es
zweimal ist nicht geworden und das was
gerade beschrieben wird aus dann wurde
er nicht aufgestellt als Spitzen
hatte ja die Wahl verloren zwei Mal aber
warum ist er dann Teil des Debakels er
hat ja einen anderen Weg aufgezeigt und
die CDU hat die nicht angenommen er war
im zukunftsteam er hat eine große Bühne
im Wahlkampf er stand hinter Laschet er
wurde mit ihm assoziiert er war gegen
Söder also das heißt die Menschen
wussten wenn ich Laschet wähle kriege
ich auch märz und sie haben trotzdem nur
24 Prozent der CDU gegeben also für mich
ist es der falsche Zeit deswegen diese
Debatte ich finde gerade aus dem Grund
Verena den du gerade angesprochen hast
wäre März der richtige weil März hat
gezeigt dass er ein Teamplayer ist März
hat sein Ego zurückgestellt hat sie auch
hinter Laschet gestellt ihm ging halt
Markus Söder eigentlich die ganze Zeit
nur gegen Laschet geschossen und ich
finde März hat gezeigt dass er sich mehr
zurücknehmen kann und das war zu dem
Zeitpunkt richtig ob er den Wahlkampf so
geführt hätte wie Laschet nein märz ist
ja auch von den Einstellungen her schon
anders ich glaube dass mir jetzt gut
wäre um die Union wieder mehr
konservativ zurück was wäre aus seiner
Sicht die richtige Debatte die die CDU
jetzt wird wie man Posten verteilt
obwohl man die Wahl verloren hat oder
welche bestimmt nicht aber anerkennen
wir haben die verloren jetzt ist einfach
auch gerade mal nicht dran dass die
bildschlagzeile ist März möchte
CDU-Vorsitzender werden also das ist so
das letzte was Deutschland gerade
interessiert wer gerade CDU-Vorsitzender
werden will also deswegen finde ich
jetzt geht in die Opposition nutzt die
Zeit der Erneuerung wenn ihr sagt man
kann sich nur in der Regierung irgendwie
neu erfinden ja dann hättet ihr
irgendwie einen anderen Wahlkampf machen
müssen aber jetzt habt ihr das was er da
habt die 24 Prozent und jetzt ist es mal
gut jetzt interessiert mich gerade
klappt die Ampel wer wird das Kabinett
aber mich interessiert gerade nicht wer
CDU ist also du gehst fest aus von
Opposition und Ampel absolut das ist
auch zumindest das was ich glaube 76
Prozent der Deutschen wollen Olaf Scholz
als Kanzler die SPD hat die Wahl
gewonnen das ist jetzt das was jetzt
diskutiert werden müsste also was ich
ganz spannend finde ist tatsächlich dass
gerade ein Friedrich Merz ja so ein
bisschen das unternehmerische
mut-prinzip verfolgt von Trial and Error
Trial and Error vielleicht kommt
irgendwann auf trial and Sax seed wir
werden sehen fakt ist aber dass die Idee
einer Urwahl total spannend ist um
endlich mal mit lila mitzunehmen weil
ich glaube das fehlt einfach und das ist
natürlich irgendwo basisdemokratisch
finde ich absolut richtig und was
definitiv passieren muss ist dass die
Union endlich mal in die Ruhe kommt weil
gerade wenn man verhandeln will finde
ich braucht man ruhige Fahrwasser total
aber wenn das das richtige ist
basisdemokratisch den CDU-Vorsitzenden
warum haben sie es denn nicht gemacht
man kann ja durchaus auch umgekehrt
argumentieren dass bei der SPD derjenige
des Bundeskanzler geworden ist der
basisdemokratisch abgelehnt worden ist
ja also auch da kann man ja durchaus
dann Zweifel daran haben ob das Modell
funktioniert wenn derjenige den die
Partei ausdrücklich nicht wollte im
ganzen Land dann offenbar ja immer noch
so gut ankommt dass er Bundeskanzler
werden werden kann aber das Problem war
ja bislang das ist bei Friedrich Merz
zweimal ein relativ einhelliges
Meinungsbild an der unionsbasis gegeben
hat für zu seinen Gunsten auch draußen
im Lande war er der beliebtere und
trotzdem hat eine leicht
funktionärsdominierte
parteitagsmannschaft dann beschlossen
nee wir das ist uns alles zu unsicher
dann räumt er am Ende wieder auf und
dann wird im adenauerhaus wieder alles
auf den Kopf gestellt dazu habe ich mal
eine Frage Ralf an Dich aber an die
ganze Runde kann sich einer von euch
erklären darin liegt ja ein bisschen
auch sozusagen das Ungemach dass die CDU
jetzt bei der Wahl erlebt hat wie man
darauf kommen konnte dass es besser ist
Akku als Parteivorsitzender zu wählen
als Friedrich Merz hätte da nicht klar
sein müssen wenn wir die schlechteste
Rede seines Lebens also akks beste und
seine schlechteste und das gleiche hat
sich noch mal bei Laschet gegen ihn
wiederholt das Laschet einen rausgehauen
wie noch nie zuvor und er nicht also ich
frage mich eher warum ist er in den
entscheidenden Momenten dann nicht da
und was ich mich auch frage will er
wirklich jetzt gerade CDU-Vorsitzender
oder ist das eine Schlagzeile die ihr
jetzt gerade macht weil das trendet
jetzt auf Twitter ich habe vor 15
Stunden von ihm gelesen er will jetzt
nicht mehr ging's establishmen schießen
er will sich jetzt als einfacher
Abgeordneter einsortieren und er würde
jetzt erstmal die Füße Stimmen er hat
gesagt er will nicht mehr gegen das
Establishment antreten
und deswegen sagt sein allererstes
Umfeld uns jetzt ganz klar
die Übersetzung davon ist er tritt aber
sofort an wenn es nicht mehr das
Establishment entscheidet sondern die
Breite der Partei also die Schlagzeile
kann ich dir versichern die kommt nicht
von uns die hat wieder reif noch ich mir
ausgedacht sondern die kommt tatsächlich
genau daher wo es im von wo es im Text
drin steht nämlich aus Friedrich Merz
sehr engem Umfeld auf Twitter das ist
das
ist das ist das ja auch teilweise
perfide Spiel in der Politik dementiert
es nicht er limitiert es nicht das ist
ein es liest sich wie ein dementia was
ist genau das Gegenteil er sagt wir
haben einen gewählten Parteivorsitzenden
ach nee und ich unterstütze seine
Bemühungen eine Koalition mit FTP und
Grünen zu bauen Übersetzung wenn das
scheitert unterstütze ich ihn nicht mehr
derzeit stellt sich die Frage nach
Parteivorsitz nicht heißt derzeit nicht
aber vielleicht schon morgen und dann
bin ich bereit es ist also ein sehr
geschickter Umgang mit diesem Satz da
steht in keiner Weise dass er nicht
antreten würde da steht nur drin dass
Armin Laschet jetzt noch irgendwie die
Chance hat etwas das zu erreichen wovon
Du ja auch sagst es wird halt nicht
funktionieren wenn nicht funktioniert
trotzdem bin ich ehrlich gesagt diese
Taktiererei etwas unsympathischer das
dominiert das gesamte Geschehen bei der
bei der Union derzeit da hat man einen
schwer angeschlagenen Parteivorsitzenden
einen Kanzlerkandidaten der dann aber
seine Deals durchdrückt in der Fraktion
in dem Ralf rinkhaus noch mal für eine
Übergangsfrist
Fraktionsvorsitzender werden dahinter
steht eigentlich dass man wahrscheinlich
am Ende des Oktober einen neuen
Vorsitzender braucht dann muss man einen
Auswahlprozess starten dann sollen aber
nicht alle gleichzeitig aus dem Bus
springen und sagen ich will und dann
braucht man ein Parteitag und dann muss
der neue Parteivorsitzende
möglicherweise dann eben auch nach dem
Fraktionsvorsitz greifen um ein Gewicht
zu sein Gegenteil was die Bürger gerade
interessiert auf interessiert einfach
gerade kein das genau all die die
irgendwie die Gesichter dieses
Scheiterns jetzt auch gerade sind alle
an ihren Stühlen gegeben und noch mal
eine Schlagzeile reinschmeißen ich will
es noch mal machen
also dieses dieses Taktieren mit
irgendwelchen Botschaften zu sagen ja
ich ich will eigentlich nicht gegen das
Tablet mit aber wenn das anders kommt
empfehle ich doch wieder an dann
hinterher aber zu sagen ich bin aber
trotzdem loyal zu Armin Laschet die
Leute wollen endlich mal ganz klare
gerade unverwogene Leute die sagen ich
will es ich trete an oder ich will es
nicht und ich trete nicht an und das
alles dabei
Olaf also ich glaube die Leute wollen
genau nicht die wollen Disziplin
anscheinend sehen man darf keine
menschliche Regelung zeigen und dann
wird man Kanzler nicht im Wahlkampf
gelernt Silvia breher glaube ich bestes
erststimm-ergebnis Carsten Linnemann
irgendwie dritt bestes
erststimm-ergebnis das sind ja echte
Menschen dann kanzlerkampf hat Olaf
Scholz gut
gezeigt hat aber auch die Raute oder
dass er für Merkel gehalten wurde oder
so gebracht haben aber ich glaube schon
noch an echte Menschen und ein Lindemann
oder eine Dreher oder eine seraphyla die
sind nicht erste Reihe aber warum nicht
das sind die gleichen weil sie so
menschlich sind oder vielleicht weil die
Partei noch nicht immer neuerungsprozess
ist weil das erst noch kommt und
deswegen ist das für mich jetzt so ein
übergangstheater was da veranstaltet
wird aus das muss noch einmal kannst du
noch einmal kurz Strecken bevor du dann
irgendwie zusammen fährst Abschlussrunde
zu dem Thema Verena wer wird der
perfekte CDU-Vorsitzende oder die
perfekten der CDU vorsitzende
keine Präferenz und keine Präferenz aber
was glaubst du wer der Beste für die CDU
ich glaube tatsächlich müssen die
Mitglieder entscheiden und deswegen
finde ich die Idee einer Urwahl spannend
und richtig ich glaube nur wir müssen
jetzt endlich mal aufhören über
Personalien zu diskutieren sondern uns
auf die Inhalte konzentrieren Ralf was
meinst du meine ganz steile These ich
glaube dass Friedrich Merz sehr viel hat
vom Markus Söder nämlich einen
kompletten gestaltungsüberdruck im
Innern Markus Söder und Friedrich Merz
können sich nicht leiden beide werfen
sich gegenseitig vor nur ein Programm zu
haben nämlich sich selbst und genau das
diesen Gestaltungswillen braucht man
jetzt klare Ansagen zu machen und nicht
zu sagen wo kann ich in den Gremien
Deals machen und die Nordrhein-Westfalen
verschieben klare Ansagen deshalb glaube
ich dass Friedrich Merz unter
gestalterischen und unter
polarisierenden Gesichtspunkten
eigentlich der bessere wäre und dann
können Sie alle dran abarbeiten so kurz
können sich bildredakteure fassen genau
was glaubst Du auf gar keinen feiern
Spahn auf gar keinen Fall deswegen ich
gebe meine Stimme dafür abzusagen wer
ist auf gar keinen Fall werden darf und
das ist entspannt das war aber nicht die
Frage ich habe keine andere Antwort
gemacht und ich möchte auf gar keinen
Fall Jens Spahn ich bleibe bei Friedrich
Merz und das habe ich am Anfang schon
[Musik]